we've been making depict videos for
years and they can be very convincing
but they always take so much time to
process well there's some brand new
software that allows us to stream deep
fakes in real time this technology is
nuts my co-workers they don't even know
this exists yet and that got me
wondering if I can actually prank them
into thinking that I'm someone else can
I fool them can I for you
what
if anybody sees I'm stuck in another
secret they're gonna know what we're
doing in the secret video one second let
me close the door
30. all right so this is where all the
Magic's gonna happen this is deep face
live and it was made by the same guy
Dipper off that made deep face slab and
deep face live basically lets you take
deep fake models and use them live in
real time
hi hi I'm Jim Carrey I'm Jim Carrey
you see that's the cool thing too is the
fingers and go like this oh the mask
said oh most kind of that's enough Jim
Carrey let's try somebody else
Sylvester Stallone
and let me let's get on the screen like
when I'm probably like a weird dude in
real life it's like playing VR you might
feel like you're cool when you're in the
game but in real life like a dork you
want Spice AKA Elon Musk
I'm a little Gremlin
I'm just dialing in my webcam I like
freaking Smeagol he eating my precious
hello I'm a lady this one's pretty good
actually
it's a little smooth but it's probably
just because that's all the sources they
used can it do slices
oh my gosh
so that's deep face live well what kind
of shenanigans can we get up to with
Steve face Live Well I had an idea here
since I have people in the studio I can
capture one of their faces making a
perfect data set and then I could deep
fake them and I could go into Discord
and using deep face live try to trick my
co-workers into thinking they're talking
to say Ren when in reality they're
talking to me with Ren's face on as a
deep fake if you remember way back in
the day when we made our Tom Cruise deep
fake I made my little test deep fake
with Ren and me and it's really junky so
I want to prove to myself that I've
improved since then so I need to go
through and I need to make a perfect
deep fake model I need to use the newest
architecture I need to use the newest
techniques and then make it look as
realistic as I can possibly make it now
when you're creating a deep fake you
need to provide the AI there's many
different examples of a face as possible
with different Expressions different
angles different lighting conditions
there's not really like a blueprint I'm
kind of making it up as I go I at least
know that the computer needs as much
variety of data that I can give it I'm
just going to take Rand and hold a bunch
of lights that are flickering I'm just
going to move them around his face
getting a whole bunch of different
lighting angles while he looks around
and just goes
in fact I have an idea here there's
sentences that you can say that have
every single phoneme which is every
sound that you make when you're speaking
are those shy Eurasian Footwear cowboy
chaps yep are those shy Asian Footwear
cowboy chaps yeah what a strange bizarre
sentence theoretically is going to cause
every single mouth shape to kind of be
formed Jolly Earth moving head here
Jolly Earth moving headgear so just with
you know five to ten minutes of
recording somebody's face downstairs I
can make a perfect face data set it's
high level VFX
[Music]
and I can do the same for myself for
training as well
so now I have my data sets I need to
train them here's my method first I take
a collection of random faces both by
destination and my source faces and I
just train on that Nvidia actually has a
collection of random faces they have
used to train their AIS that you can
grab for free so this trains the defect
just to simply draw a face where are the
eyes where's the nose where's the mouth
what does it generally look like because
starting out the AI knows nothing the D
fake is just going to draw a gray Square
so once I've trained it how to draw a
basic face I need a train to draw a
specific face this is where I swap out
part of the data set with Ren's face so
I'm using all the random faces as my
destination I'm using red as my source
so little by little the Deep thick is
learning to draw Ren's face correctly in
any situation the next step is to
specialize it and train it to draw
rand's face on my face because for
example I have a bit of a mustache here
and if it's been trained on random faces
it may not see this as a mustache it may
see it as somebody just going hmm and
like tucking the lip or having some
Shadow here so by training the Deep fake
at its last stage on my face it gets my
Expressions correct and with that I get
the highest quality version of Ren's
face than being defect onto my face
here's the thing the final model I want
to make is going to be pretty high risk
it's probably going to take about two
weeks to train I'm running out of a
machine with three 30 90s in it thanks
to Puget that's right because Puget
makes these banging computers so I can
actually throw some real AI stuff at
them and just let them crunch so we're
gonna let that bake in the oven for a
solid two weeks here a fortnight if you
will and then I'm gonna give Ryan a call
as himself
Nico's been doing a pretty good job
keeping this video a secret from
everybody in the studio but he could be
doing better you see the best way to
keep a secret especially to keep your
data secret as it exists out on the open
internet is to use today's sponsor
expressvpn
expressvpn wraps your internet data in a
layer of additional encryption that
allows you to have protection against
hackers and other Bad actors who might
be out trying to get your data on the
open Internet it's pretty great but it's
not even the best thing about expressvpn
the thing that we like best about
expressvpn is that it allows you to
access content like Rick and Morty which
might not otherwise be available in your
country or region this allows us to tell
the internet that we're in one place and
access the content in a country or
region we're not in it's really great
because you can unlock a bunch of shows
and movies that you might not otherwise
be able to see
I don't even think Nico knows about it
but there it is big secret
wow but hey if that's not enough for you
just know expressvpn is one of the
fastest vpns out there because they have
servers in over 94 countries they've
been rated number one VPN service by
CNET and tech radar and you can get
three months free by clicking the link
in the description below or going to
expressvpn.com
that's three months free by clicking the
link in the description below or going
to expr ESS vpn.com Corridor crew so if
you have any other Secrets let me know
because uh
well I'm not hiding anything
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is so bizarre to look at what I
never realized until just now that
Nico's got a wider face than I do
[Laughter]
what the heck man
in fact that is doing this got my teeth
he's got my teeth this is the wildest
sweet okay I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
talk to Nico this is
great hi that's a secret info right
there
[Music]
does that feel weird
that was such a bizarre experience I
don't even know how to
that man that was me but it was like
weird I'm gonna do the test repair here
lean into the shot
foreign
let's try making the same face again
ready do this one
[Music]
okay now this one
[Laughter]
you gotta you got a way more square jaw
than I do yeah oh yeah here
will it work at all
yeah it's on you right now wait what
wait is it yeah no
what the world dude it's doing all this
in real time no it's crazy
wow it was literally just like a year or
two ago we're doing this and just doing
it all was groundbreaking and now we're
just it's real time stick your face in
there again yeah
[Music]
god dude I look so mean you look really
strange
come here come here come here come here
do I smell secrets
you're getting a call okay oh
uh I Ran hey this is weird it's a mix
oh my gosh who do you look like it's
like not quite fully Wren dude it's it's
the little whisks your hair in the back
you gotta you gotta get those out of
there you're just way too mellow for Rin
like act more enthusiastic hey hey red
hot dog hot dog hot dog
it's so weird dude do you think Nico's
gonna fool anyone with this I think Nico
could definitely fool people with this
you need a you need to do everything
else that's ran as well as the face you
know like the body language the little
mannerisms I think Nico should watch
some some Ren Vlogs and like you know
how does ren sit you know when he's on a
video call how does Ron sit how does he
carry himself what does he do when he's
happy and talks does he move his head a
lot because Nico is much more like
mellow and kind of like reserved and
that's what's throwing me off the most
right now
well it's gonna be a little touch and go
to see if I can really convince people
that I'm in
um it's pretty close but I really need
to like channel the the man himself I
can't just be the face it needs to be
The Full Experience
all right so the Deep fake model is
looking pretty good I didn't quite get
to the last stage of Gan training which
gives it like really fine details but
this is this is gonna be on like a
webcam Discord I'm not worried about
that I'm ready to rock and roll okay I
guess it's time I'm gonna go I'm gonna
go hide so today's the big day here's
the plan
Daniel is going to pull people down into
the sound room for a little segment he's
something about Discord for crew cuts to
show on our website so what do you need
me to do you need me to uh could you go
ahead and call up I'm gonna sit down
they're gonna call Ren so just call him
up is he ready to go
I have no idea what's going on but I
know something's going on I think we can
really get him
two stories
there he is
yeah I see him yeah I see him yeah
what's up Ryan
[Music]
yeah I do
uh he's I guess he's muted or something
can you hear me can you hear us
Ryan can you not hear me
I can see you but I can't hear you
I can't hear a run right now oh go ahead
and unmute yourself
there you go
[Music]
he's still muted friend can you hear me
you can hear me
you can hear
me I just can't hear you
can you hear me run
[Music]
why do you look
weird it was a little different today
yeah I don't know yeah I don't normally
wear hats is that it
it's the hat isn't it I don't normally I
don't normally wear hats
that is that is not Wren at all
[Music]
deep fake or something if I've ever seen
it
what do you mean
I'm not sure what you're talking about
I don't like this what do you not like
[Music]
y'all are [ __ ] with me right now I
think you're supposed to hit the other
button oh my God
[Music]
your face
yeah his mic's not working I guess
that was very scary
that was very scary Red
that was
truly frightening
what the [ __ ] is going on
what are you guys doing what is this let
me see if I can make this audio work
here yeah I don't know about that holy
[ __ ]
scared the [ __ ] out of me
whether you can hear me or not what do
you think it is oh my God
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's freaking Eco what's wrong Peter
here we go
I think you might need it it's yeah it's
so freaking dude
it's like a trip is that Nico I thought
it looked like an old man filter on what
the
what is this wow oh what wait
now everybody's just popping up his wren
oh my God
this is insane
that's really good this is pretty good
you didn't suspect anything not even not
even a little bit oh my God you got me
so bad dude
okay
interesting I am very confused I didn't
know this was possible you seriously did
get me for like the first 10 seconds I
was just confused
I knew there was something fishy here
but I thought you were still like in the
room doing something and
uh okay I'll say this as I as I sat down
I doubled I did a double take like when
I saw you for the first time I thought
that doesn't if I wasn't already feeling
sus about there being a curtain on the
window I knew it was a defect it's a
deep fake right you're right you're the
first person to completely nail it
instantly
and they say I'm not a visual effects
artists
I knew this was some deep thing you knew
it instantly you knew it immediately
I've done enough VAR to know like I just
instantly see [ __ ] now
actually looks like red wearing like a
like an older version others I I do
there's something up with his face but
like brows what's the third brow yeah
your red model is like he is resting
devious face
he's like even still see look at that
evil
well like when you pick their hand I was
like dude I was like I know your hand
isn't that hairy and stuff like I just
like I saw like a point and it was like
that's Nico like or somebody else or
Nico smile isn't the same as exactly
yours no exactly there was some facial
expressions where I was like this is not
rain like this is there's no way it's
still a deep fake live but that's that's
insane like that's
I'm still registering
go dudes oh that was great
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
it worked most people figured out 10
seconds in but you know what we actually
got some people legitimately duped and
we surprised him with Ren being in the
same room when they thought he was on
the video call dude I realize that like
as talking I could literally get up and
be in the shot the entire time for like
five minutes
aggressively closer and closer
I think the Deep thing itself is totally
fine it's the face shape that's part of
the big issue and obviously voice is a
challenge but yeah it it's OMSI treated
just right we can make it work dude yeah
this is exciting and scary at the same
time the only thing scary about it is
how many cool things you can make with
it so I think it actually worked out
pretty well all things considered I
definitely learned a lot in this process
and I do have an idea I think it'd be
hilarious to go onto something like
Omegle and defeat yourself so look like
a celebrity to see if we could actually
trick people into thinking that they're
talking to someone famous
so if you'd like to see that video we'll
subscribe and perhaps leave a comment
down below as to who you think we should
pretend to be we're going to do that
well thank you for watching and I'll see
you guys in the next one